Surrey denier World Economic Forum I'm
coming from the panel on India Inc
creating global livelihoods and the
panel provided some very interesting
perspective on why Indian companies are
going overseas and mainly they are going
operating in the global market through
acquisitions not expansion they're going
searching for markets and getting to
consumers increased profitability in
terms of return on investment and
finding places for capital that they are
generating domestically in India they
are also able to get skill sets from
overseas that they can then bring back
to their operations all over the globe
and in that regard they are able to
create job opportunities in overseas
markets and especially in emerging
markets because they are able to take
the experiences they have in India from
creating products and services for the
lower segment of the market that are low
cost products that they are able to
bring to emerging markets we talked
quite a bit about investment in Tanzania
Tanzania provides a good enabling
environment and a good regulatory
environment in terms of attracting
investment from India and Tanzania is
looking for India to do more investment
in their country so Indian companies
expanding overseas is happening very
fast generating economic growth overseas
generating job creation overseas
developing skill sets and I think very
soon we are going to see many more
Indian companies being global
multinationals and being part of the
fortune 500 and the FT 500 as well